all right let's have some fun uh we are
going to do
a whirlwind tour through the last 24
hours on fox news
as joe biden officially won the
electoral college donald trump lost it
we already talked about this
officially yesterday december 14th state
electors
voting and joe biden got 306 electoral
votes it is over it was over before
it's extra over now so all sorts of
people appeared on fox news
and they were dealing with this loss in
a variety of different ways
joe biden said during his speech last
night when he addressed the nation
that donald trump attempted an assault
on democracy in trying to steal the
election and that's accurate and that
leads to our first clip
here is donald trump's press secretary
and
senior campaign advisor which one she
was last night i don't know
reacting to joe biden's accurate claim
about
donald trump trying to assault democracy
and she's really upset guys
in this just before coming to air we
heard joe biden
say that there was an assault on
democracy
by president trump asking for a free and
fair election
that's preposterous how fitting is your
monologue tonight the assault on
democracy
was the four-year attack going after
president trump the baseless moeller
allegations
uh the the impeachment over a one
whistleblower with hearsay
so she's very upset there or at least
pretending to be
and this is just so simple but they want
to make it more complex
joe biden won this election because he
won enough states
to get more than 270 electoral votes
that's it
and then donald trump despite losing try
to remain in power so
it is an assault on the democratic will
of the people period end of story very
simple
they either don't get it or they pretend
not to get it here's laura ingram in our
next clip
sort of begrudgingly conceding that it
is president-elect joe biden
but she had to do it in a sarcastic tone
okay take a look
following the electoral college vote
today president-elect
joe biden spoke to the nation tonight
listen as long as you acknowledge that
he's president-elect
i don't care if you use a minnie mouse
voice i don't care if you say
president-elect joe biden
as chewbacca i don't care as long as
you're
understanding that joe biden is the
president-elect this next one is just
delightful
even trump supporter and friend of trump
geraldo rivera has to admit
it's over and wild trump sycophant
charlie kirk
just can't take it and starts arguing
with geraldo live on air let's first
listen to what geraldo had to say the
modern history of our country
but to persist in insisting against the
supreme court against the
scores of lawsuits that have gone
against him every single one of them
that he won that's why these people they
believe him
they love him they are following his
lead
it is the president who is instilling in
these people
the false sense that they have been
gypped
charlie makes the point that there are
the so many uh affidavits or hero there
you litigate each one of them if
someone's guilty of election fraud you
put them in jail
the attorney general the united states
william bohr said that there is no fraud
that he has seen of a scope large enough
to affect the outcome of this election
charlie make a closing comment here
charlie go ahead so i'm not
thrilled with geraldo's use of the word
egypt it's sort of like
saying you've been jude i'm not
canceling geraldo it's not the main
point of the clip
but i've stopped using that term but the
sentiment here is correct and charlie
kirk
doesn't like it and if you try to say
something sensible on fox news you get
attacked and that's what happened here
and here's charlie kirk very upset with
geraldo elections were
very much on the margins especially in
georgia and arizona and you suppress
that conversation that is not healthy
for our country herald though all right
so that raises the question
for six weeks we have litigated this for
six weeks twice the supreme court of the
united states
have rejected it nine to nothing
including all three
trump associate justices
so that's pretty funny they they just
can't take it
and then as a sort of contrast here's
the news side of fox news
which is often not very newsy but even
they did say yesterday brett baer saying
joe biden has officially won well what
is normally a rubber stamp process
was anything but today and moments ago
the electoral college voted
for president in what may be its most
watched event in decades
making joe biden the 46th president
of the united states right now
president-elect correspondent brian yen
such an uncontroversial statement that
one from brett bayer
which got magga twitter absolutely
furious with brett bayer and these are
some
wild times that we live in and a little
bit later i'm actually going to talk
about a very interesting
sort of milestone for fox news a
negative milestone
regarding ratings and the bigger picture
is i am very curious to see what fox
news will look like
um january 21st and beyond not that much
longer now we'll know very soon
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now and you can take advantage of
it by going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black
watch and i love the sleek minimalist
design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
five-star reviews because you won't find
a better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now and free
shipping when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video